- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La séance est ouverte.
L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
La première va être posée par la
présidente Mathilde Panot pour le
groupe La France Insoumise.
- Mathilde Panot: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, vous
céderez.
Vous céderez, car vous ne tenez
qu'à 9 voix.
2 Français sur 3
souhaitent votre départ.
Vous céderez car la police seule
ne parviendra pas à faire régner
l'ordre.
Vous céderez car un caprice du
président ne mérite pas de menacer
la paix civile du pays.
Vous céderez car votre réforme des
retraites relève d'un choix
politique et qu'il est possible
d'en faire un tout autre.
Vous céderez car au fond, vous
vous enlisez dans une crise de
régime inutile.
Oui, vous céderez car il n'y aura
pas de retour à la normale
possible sans céder.
Vous céderez, mais qu'est-ce que
vous laisserez?
Vous céderez, mais vous aurez
abîmé comme rarement la parole
politique.
Vous avez instrumentalisé la
Constitution à des fins
autoritaire.
Vous avez joué avec une roulette
russe quand ce n'est pas un jeu de
pile ou face, vous avez bafoué la
démocratie sociale en traitant les
syndicats comme des figurants,
vous avez attaqué le droit de
grève et de manifestations à coup
de réquisition et de répression.
Vous avez fait honte à la France.
Vous céderez, et au moment où vous
céderez, il sera déjà trop tard,
car de votre pouvoir, il ne
restera que des débris.
Madame la Première ministre, un
peu de courage.
Il ne reste à Emmanuel Macron plus
beaucoup d'options.
Retrait du texte ou retour devant
le peuple.
Combien de temps encore le
président de la République va-t-il
nous faire perdre du temps avant
de céder?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
madame la présidente Mathilde
Panot, les mots ont un sens.
Autoritarisme, c'est le mot que
vous employez pour parler de notre
Constitution.
Illégitime, c'est le mot que vous
utilisez pour décrire le
Parlement, le débat, les
institutions.
"Assassin", c'est l'insulte qu'a
hurlé l'un de vos députés en
attaquant le ministre du Travail.
Dégoût, fureur, ce sont vos
paroles d'hier dans un registre
haineux qui est désormais votre
habitude.
Censure populaire, ce sont les
mots de Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
appelant au soulèvement face au
parlement.
Madame la présidente Mathilde
Panot, hier soir, votre violence
verbale a débordé dans la rue.
Sans surprise, vous n'avez plus de
mots pour condamner les violences.
Au contraire, vous continuez sans
relâche vos attaques systématiques
des institutions républicaines.
Vous vous en prenez aux policiers
et aux gendarmes.
Vous remettez en cause leur
travail, leur comportement.
Tout signalement est
systématiquement examiné.
Pour ma part, je veux leur rendre
hommage.
Ils nous protègent et protègent
nos institutions, ainsi que
l'ordre républicain.
Je veux dire notre solidarité aux
400 policiers et gendarmes blessés
ces derniers jours, dont 42 cette
nuit.
Je veux saluer enfin nos
sapeurs-pompiers qui ont été
fortement mobilisés.
Alors, madame la présidente
Mathilde Panot, moi aussi, j'ai
quelques mots à partager que vos
dernières interventions et
l'attitude de votre groupe ces
dernières semaines m'ont rappelé.
Le premier, c'est duplicité.
On vous entend vous plaindre de ne
pas avoir pu aller jusqu'au bout
du texte alors que vous avez tout
fait pour le bloquer!
Antiparlementarisme, c'est toute
votre ligne politique, à force
d'opposer la légitimité de la rue
au Parlement.
Intimidation, ce sont les actes
que vous justifiez en minimisant
les dégradations et les menaces à
l'encontre des parlementaires ces
dernières semaines.
Madame la présidente Panot, avec
votre groupe, vous êtes des
représentants de la nation, alors
respectez le résultat des urnes et
les votes au Parlement.
Respectez nos institutions et
respectez enfin notre démocratie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Yannick
Neuder.
- Yannick Neuder: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question concerne monsieur le
ministre de la Santé.
Je voudrais évoquer deux sujets
qui sont importants pour la santé
de nos concitoyens.
Le premier, la prise en charge des
accidents vasculaires cérébraux.
150.000 patients par an en sont
victimes.
1 Français sur 5 en fera un durant
sa vie.
Sur les 577 députés que nous
sommes, 115 en seront victimes.
Le 24 février, vous avez arrêté de
rembourser la sonde qui permet
d'extraire le caillot.
Le deuxième sujet concerne la
prise en charge des
chimiothérapies, et vous avez
décidé de ne plus rembourser les
molécules de chimiothérapie
exercée en hôpital de jour, sous
réserve qu'elles représentent 30%
du forfait.
Donc, je voudrais mettre fin à
cette insincérité et cette
hypocrisie.
Je suis fier de porter aujourd'hui
la jonquille, témoin de la
recherche pour le cancer, mais je
trouve scandaleux que l'on fasse
choisir à nos centres de
cancérologie de faire des
chimiothérapies ou de payer la
note de chauffage.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur François Braun.
- François Braun: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député, il n'y a ni
hypocrisie, ni insincérité.
Vous parlez de médicaments et de
dispositifs médicaux qui ont été
mis dans la liste en sus.
Elle est destinée aux médicaments
et aux dispositifs médicaux
innovants et onéreux.
Cela permet de les financer de
façon dérogatoire en plus du
financement du séjour hospitalier.
Leur coût ne permet pas d'être
intégré dans le forfait
hospitalier.
Il y a des médicaments et des
dispositifs qui entrent et qui
sortent.
Cela ne veut pas dire qu'ils ne
sont plus remboursés, mais cela
veut dire qu'ils sont pris en
charge dans le coût du séjour
hospitalier.
Au 1er mars, après deux ans de
discussions avec les industriels
concernés, des anticancéreux, des
antifongiques ont été supprimés de
cette liste, car ils étaient
suffisamment anciens pour
réintégrer le mode de financement
habituel.
C'est la même chose pour le
cathéter dont vous parlez.
Lui aussi est toujours disponible
dans les établissements de santé.
Il est intégré dans le financement
global du séjour hospitalier.
C'est quelque chose qui reste
habituel, récurrent.
Il y a une cagnotte financière
mise de côté pour aider
l'établissement qui, dans la
période de transition,
n'arriverait pas à faire face à
cette dépense, mais en aucun cas
cela veut dire que ces produits ne
sont plus utilisés ou seraient
inefficaces.
Ils sont toujours pris en charge
dans le cadre du forfait
hospitalier.
- Yannick Neuder: Monsieur le
ministre, vos explications ne sont
pas là pour rassurer les patients,
et surtout les médecins ou les
sociétés savantes.
Ces préconisations que vous faites
sont contre celles de la Haute
Autorité de Santé.
A l'heure où nous sommes, ce n'est
pas le moment de supprimer ces
remboursements.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
au président Laurent Marcangeli.
- Laurent Marcangeli: Madame la
Première ministre, notre pays
traverse actuellement une période
troublée.
Un constat s'impose à tous, celui
de vives inquiétudes de nos
concitoyens quant à leur avenir.
Les sujets de préoccupation ne
manquent pas.
Une inflation se rajoute au
spectre d'une potentielle crise
bancaire.
La guerre en Ukraine s'enlise.
L'actualité nous a rappelés la
nécessité de faire tout notre
possible pour lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique.
Il en va de notre présent et de
celui des générations futures.
La conséquence, c'est un contexte
de tensions, notamment sociales.
Je ne nierai pas que la
désapprobation que suscite le
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la Sécurité
sociale adopté hier joue un rôle
dans leur mise à jour, mais il ne
faudrait pas prétendre qu'il ne
s'agit que de cela.
C'est autre chose qui est en train
de se jouer dans la société
française.
Il s'agit d'une appétence légitime
pour la correction des injustices
sociales et territoriales.
Je pense par exemple aux enjeux
majeurs de l'accès aux soins ou
aux services publics.
C'est dans ce climat que la
tension sociale se pose.
Cette question, c'est celle de
notre rapport à la valeur travail.
Le groupe Horizons en est
convaincu: le travail amène à la
prospérité, et la prospérité
garantit l'élévation du niveau de
vie de chacun.
Nous pensons que la question du
partage de l'effort productif doit
être plus que jamais posée sur la
table.
Madame la Première ministre,
personne ne doute, ici, de votre
engagement pour fixer un cap clair
pour rassurer les Français.
Pouvez-vous dire à la
représentation nationale quelles
seront les grands axes de travail
du gouvernement dans les prochains
mois pour contribuer à réduire les
injustices?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, hier, après
175 heures de débats, la réforme
des retraites, fruit d'un
compromis entre l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat, fruit du
travail et de tous les
parlementaires qui voulaient
garantir l'avenir de nos
retraites, a été adopté.
Je veux saluer à nouveau le
travail des parlementaires de la
majorité qui ont permis
d'améliorer ce texte et qui ont
fait bloc à chaque étape.
Monsieur le président Laurent
Marcangeli, je sais notamment le
travail et l'implication de votre
groupe, qui a porté des
propositions pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt, pour la
prise en compte des trimestres de
travaux d'utilité collective pour
la retraite, ou encore pour que
notre système ne rajoute pas de
l'injustice à la douleur de la
perte d'un jeune enfant.
Je veux également profiter de ce
moment pour saluer à nouveau les
parlementaires hors de la majorité
qui ont participé à bâtir ce
compromis.
Ils ont été fidèles aux principes
de leur famille politique et
fidèles à la demande des Français
de nous voir travailler ensemble,
au-delà des postures et des
intérêts personnels.
Monsieur le président Laurent
Marcangeli, cette réforme est
nécessaire.
Comme vous l'avez souligné, elle
soulève des inquiétudes et des
interrogations chez nos
concitoyens.
Elle renvoie à des questions plus
larges.
Sur notre rapport au travail, sur
l'évolution des carrières, sur la
manière de répartir justement
l'effort.
Mon objectif, celui de notre
gouvernement, c'est de répondre à
nos interrogations.
Nous souhaitons que l'accord sur
le partage de la valeur trouvé
entre les partenaires sociaux soit
retranscrit rapidement dans la
loi.
C'est pourquoi nous continuerons
dans les prochains mois à chercher
les meilleures réponses aux
préoccupations des Français.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
pour y parvenir, nous ne
renoncerons jamais à chercher des
compromis et à travailler au plus
tôt avec les parlementaires.
Pour y parvenir, nous voulons plus
que jamais prendre appui sur la
démocratie sociale, notamment en
retranscrivant les accords trouvés
par les organisations syndicales
et patronales.
Pour y parvenir, nous devons
continuer à nous appuyer sur les
territoires et associer davantage
nos concitoyens à la prise de
décision.
Monsieur le président Marcangeli,
je sais que je peux compter sur la
majorité pour nous aider à mener
ce travail et je veux compter,
au-delà des clivages, sur tous les
députés qui veulent agir pour
notre pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Sébastien
Chenu.
- Sébastien Chenu: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à la
Première ministre.
Nous savons désormais que nous
n'avons plus rien à attendre du
président de la République, ni
sincérité, ni respect, ni écoute
des Français, ni considération du
gouvernement.
Vous avez acté hier comme une
gifle supplémentaire avec ce 49.3
l'ampleur du mépris que vous
portez à la France.
C'est évidemment la fin d'une
certaine idée de la démocratie
parlementaire, mais c'est surtout
la négation du peuple français et
la négation de la volonté
populaire.
Hier, sans aucun doute, sans
aucune once de doute, vous avez
prouvé que le pouvoir dans notre
pays est représenté par un homme,
par une seule idée, par une seule
idéologie.
Vous avez ensuite, avec cynisme,
saisi le Conseil constitutionnel,
comme si vous étiez la partie la
plus lésée dans cette affaire,
alors que ce sont les Français qui
sont lésés.
Votre loi n'a aucune légitimité
politique.
Vous avez tout raté: la bataille
de l'opinion politique, les
concertations inexistantes, le
passage devant l'Assemblée
nationale, même une fausse
opposition.
Madame la Première ministre, ma
question est simple:
qu'attendez-vous pour rendre le
meilleur service que vous pouvez
rendre à notre République,
c'est-à-dire de démissionner?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député Chenu, de quoi
parlez-vous?
De quoi parlez-vous lorsque vous
remettez en cause la légitimité du
texte qui a été adopté hier par le
Parlement?
Ce texte est allé au bout de son
cheminement démocratique.
Ce texte, c'est un engagement du
président de la République pris
pendant la campagne.
C'est un engagement pris par
l'ensemble de la majorité
présidentielle.
C'est un texte qui a été étudié
pendant des mois de concertation
avec les partenaires sociaux.
C'est un texte qui a connu 175
heures de débats, qui n'a pas pu
aller au bout de son examen à
cause de l'obstruction, mais qui a
été adopté par le Sénat dans son
intégralité.
Ce texte, il va permettre des
avancées dès le 1er septembre.
Allez-vous dire non à la
revalorisation des petites
retraites?
Allez-vous dire non à la meilleure
prise en compte de la pénibilité?
Allez-vous dire non à
l'amélioration pour les seniors?
Nous allons continuer dans
l'intérêt des Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur
Sébastien Chenu?
- Sébastien Chenu: Vous avez
empêché avec madame la Première
ministre le vote parce que vous
alliez le perdre.
Vous alliez perdre ce vote devant
la représentation nationale.
Monsieur le ministre, rendez-vous
utile, accompagnez madame Borne
vers la sortie.
- Olivier Dussopt: Monsieur le
député, il y a une chose qui est
sûre, peut-être la seule chose de
vraie dans ce que vous avez dit,
ce n'est pas vous qui avez empêché
le débat, parce que vous avez été
muet.
Votre projet qui coûte 26
milliards d'euros aurait ruiné les
Français et les petits retraités.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Eric
Bothorel.
- Eric Bothorel: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres, cette question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
Affaires étrangères.
Hier, Olivier Dubois a été libéré.
Plus de 700 jours loin des siens.
Applaudissements nourris
...
711 jours loin des siens, et ce
matin, les doutes, les questions
cèdent leur place à la joie de
retrouver la famille, les amis,
les collègues...
On a parlé de lui à la
radio, dans la presse, égrené les
jours, comme sur certains comptes
Twitter, le nom d'Olivier Dubois a
toujours été plus qu'un murmure
qui s'étend dans la nuit profonde,
propice parfois à l'oubli.
La France n'abandonne pas les
siens, jamais.
Au-delà de la joie que nous
partageons de revoir Olivier se
pose une question bien plus
pragmatique, quand percevra-t-il
son indemnisation?
Le fonds de garantie des victimes
que nous possédons nous donne
beaucoup de raisons de nous
réjouir.
Pourtant, on peut avoir le
sentiment de devoir se justifier
pendant des années les
maltraitances.
Pour mémoire, certains otages
capturés il y a 10 ans n'ont
toujours pas reçu leur offre
définitive, tout comme des
victimes du 13 novembre.
Le fonds de garantie des victimes
réclame toujours plus de pièces.
L'argent ne guérit pas les
stigmates du terrorisme, mais il
aide à donner les moyens aux
victimes d'envisager l'avenir.
Comment peut-on améliorer ce
processus indemnitaire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Catherine Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
Olivier Dubois est de retour,
enfin.
Enfin.
Il était otage d'un groupe
depuis le 8 avril 2021.
Depuis le premier jour, sa
libération était une priorité de
la France.
Elle a été pleinement mobilisée
dans cet objectif, désormais
atteint.
Vous le savez, nous devons souvent
agir avec discrétion, tout en
tenant les familles informées
autant que nous le pouvons.
Je sais que notre discrétion n'est
parfois pas comprise.
Elle est pourtant la condition de
l'efficacité.
Aujourd'hui, je ressens encore le
soulagement et la joie, l'émotion
aussi, bien sûr, le bonheur de sa
famille, de ses proches, de ses
enfants, et je ressens le bonheur
de sa profession.
Nous avons besoin d'une presse
libre indépendante et de qualité
pour assurer notre démocratie.
Je remercie à nouveau les
autorités du Niger pour leur aide,
qui a été déterminante.
Olivier Dubois continuera de
bénéficier du soutien de l'Etat.
Le président l'a rappelé le 11
mars, lors de la cérémonie
d'hommage aux victimes du
terrorisme aux Invalides, nous
sommes du côté, pour toujours, des
victimes du terrorisme.
Le fonds de garantie a pu
indemniser 95% des victimes des
attentats de 2015 et 2016 et il a
versé près de 300 millions
d'euros.
Oui, cela nécessite souvent des
expertises médicales précises, des
expertises scientifiques et des
délais.
Pour autant, notre système est
souvent pris en modèle en Europe.
Je terminerai en rappelant que si
certains de nos compatriotes sont
encore retenus arbitrairement en
Iran, nous pensons aussi à eux.
Nous sommes pleinement mobilisés
pour obtenir leur libération.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Fabien
Roussel.
- Fabien Roussel: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, c'est
avec une extrême gravité que je
m'adresse à vous, alors même que
le pays vous signifie que votre
coup de force sur la retraite à 64
ans est non seulement
inadmissible, mais dangereux.
Quand le peuple rejette aussi
massivement votre réforme, quand
toutes les organisations
syndicales font front commun,
quand le parlement est piétiné,
c'est la France et la République
que vous abîmez.
Non seulement vous plongez le pays
dans une crise profonde, mais en
plus, vous faites le choix de la
matraque, de la répression
syndicale et des réquisitions pour
faire taire maintenant la
contestation.
Je vous le dis solennellement,
madame la Première ministre, face
au chaos que vous provoquez par
vos choix, nous ne répondrons pas
par le chaos.
Nous appelons au respect du
peuple, de la démocratie sociale,
au respect des organisations
syndicales avec qui vous ne
dialoguez plus depuis le 10
janvier.
Nous appelons aussi au respect du
Parlement.
160 députés issus de cinq groupes
comptent déposer cet après-midi un
recours au Conseil
constitutionnel.
255 parlementaires issus de neuf
groupes, du Sénat et de
l'Assemblée nationale, ont aussi
déposé une demande de référendum
d'initiative partagée inscrite
dans notre Constitution.
Allez-vous dire que cette démarche
serait illégitime?
Rien que ces recours doivent vous
conduire à ne va promulguer la
loi.
Respectez-les.
Respectez-nous.
Respectez ces millions de salariés
encore en grève, pacifiquement,
qui manifesteront ce jeudi 23
mars.
J'en profite pour rappeler aux
Français qu'il faut en faire la
plus puissante des mobilisations
de notre pays.
Madame la Première ministre,
rendez les armes.
Retirez votre réforme des
retraites.
Les Français ont besoin de
retrouver la confiance dans leur
démocratie, dans leur République.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Avant de revenir sur la réforme
des retraites, je tiens à vous
dire deux choses en écho à votre
question.
La première, vous avez utilisé
l'expression "La répression par la
matraque".
C'est une expression que je ne
peux pas accepter.
Cette expression me permet de dire
le soutien de tout le gouvernement
aux forces de police qui assurent
l'ordre, qui ramènent l'ordre dans
les rues de Paris, qui sous
l'autorité du ministre de
l'Intérieur, protègent les élus.
Leur travail doit être salué.
Le maintien de l'ordre, c'est
aussi le maintien de la liberté et
de la capacité d'expression libre
pour chacun.
La deuxième chose que je ne peux
pas partager, c'est lorsque vous
dites que le Parlement a été
piétiné.
Il y a eu 175 heures de débat.
Le seul moment où le Parlement n'a
pas pu délibérer, c'est lorsque
les groupes de gauche ont organisé
une obstruction systématique pour
empêcher l'Assemblée nationale de
délibérer et qu'ils ont privé
l'Assemblée de débat.
Vous nous appelez à la
responsabilité.
La responsabilité, c'est de mener
la réforme maintenant.
Il y a un déficit.
Le déficit n'est pas en pause.
Il continue à se creuser.
Etre responsable, c'est garantir
l'avenir du système par
répartition et l'avenir d'un
système de retraite.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Géraldine
Bannier.
- Géraldine Bannier: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre de
l'Education nationale et de la
Jeunesse.
Monsieur le ministre, le
baccalauréat est la porte d'entrée
du système supérieur, avec la
charge symbolique qu'il revêt, les
émois qu'il suscite pour des
jeunes qui passent leur premier
véritable examen.
Les épreuves de spécialité du
baccalauréat ont commencé hier.
Elles comptent pour près d'un
tiers de la note finale et pour la
première fois, se déroulent selon
le calendrier prévu, bousculé par
la Covid ces deux dernières
années.
Le contexte social lié à la
réforme des retraites inquiète
dans la mesure où des blocages
d'établissements ou des grèves de
surveillants peuvent venir
perturber les épreuves.
On imagine l'angoisse des lycéens
qui préparent ces épreuves et la
position délicate des professeurs,
forcément attachés à la réussite
de leurs élèves.
L'autorité est trop souvent remise
en question dans notre société.
Votre ministère a indiqué que des
surveillants supplémentaires ont
été convoqués.
Il ne semblait pas exclu que l'on
puisse recourir aux préfets pour
accéder aux centres d'examen.
Pouvez-vous nous faire un point de
la situation?
Combien d'élèves n'ont pas pu
passer leurs épreuves?
Quelles possibilités pour eux de
le faire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la députée, l'organisation
du baccalauréat se déroule dans
des conditions normales, prévues
par la réforme, après les
difficultés que nous avons connues
en raison de la crise sanitaire
ces deux dernières années.
C'est une grosse machine, 536.000
candidats, 2600 centres d'examen
et 35.000 correcteurs.
Les épreuves de spécialité se
déroulent tout à fait normalement
à ce jour.
Il n'y a pas eu de difficultés
hier.
Il n'y en a pas à ma connaissance
aujourd'hui, à l'exception d'une
fuite pour ce qui concerne la
série STMG, qui nécessite
d'imprimer les sujets de secours,
cet après-midi.
Nous n'attendons pas de
difficultés particulières demain.
Vous l'avez dit, nous avons prévu
des surveillants en surnombre qui
ont été mobilisés ça et là, hier
et aujourd'hui.
Nous avons veillé à ce que les
blocages n'empêchent pas les
candidats d'entrer dans les
centres d'examen.
Aucun candidat n'a été empêché
d'entrer dans un centre d'examen.
Nous allons suivre, après la
numérisation de toutes les copies,
la progression des corrections
jusqu'au 11 avril.
Donc, jusqu'à présent, les
conditions se déroulent tout à
fait normalement.
Je tiens à saluer d'ailleurs la
responsabilité de celles et ceux
qui ont appelé à ce que les
épreuves de spécialité se
déroulent normalement.
Nous ferons un bilan après la
session du baccalauréat, notamment
du point de vue des programmes,
pour envisager ce qui peut être
aménagé, mais à ce stade, nous
n'avons pas de craintes quant à
l'organisation générale de la
session 2023 du baccalauréat.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Géraldine Bannier: Merci,
monsieur le ministre pour ces
propos rassurants et pour votre
vigilance.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Andy
Kerbrat.
- Andy Kerbrat: Madame la
présidente, monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur, je cite une
victime:" Il faut que je fouille
dans ta culotte, tu es sale, ça me
dégoûte, tu sens mauvais."
Qui a bien pu dire ça en glissant
la main dans les parties génitales
d'une étudiante?
Des prédateurs sexuels?
Des criminels?
Il s'agit de policiers, lors d'une
fouille au corps mardi dernier
dans ma circonscription.
Quatre jeunes femmes ont porté
plainte, une enquête de l'IGPN est
ouverte.
Rendez-vous hommage à ces agents
et sanctionnez-vous ces pratiques
et allez-vous suspendre les agents
pendant l'enquête?
Il s'agit de votre responsabilité.
Alors que vous vous portez garants
de la liberté de manifester,
depuis l'application du 49.3, vos
consignes organisent la brutalité
policière, comme avec les gilets
jaunes.
Partout en France, les faits sont
accablants,
les placements en garde à vue
semble-t-il se multiplient.
Rien que jeudi soir, 292
interpellations, 283 ont été
classés sans suite.
Combien de jours encore
continuerez-vous à organiser la
détention arbitraire dans notre
pays?
Nous sommes dans un moment de
contestation politique largement
soutenu.
Votre réponse, c'est le
matraquage, les bombes de
désencerclement et les tirs
tendus.
Vos méthodes violentes visent à
faire peur aux Français.
La politique de la terreur et de
la privation de liberté se déploie
à marche forcée.
La Ligue des droits de l'homme
vous condamne, le syndicat de
l'administration vous condamne.
Le rapporteur spécial des Nations
Unies vous condamne.
Le désordre, ce ne sont pas les
manifestations ni les grèves,
c'est vous avec votre réforme, vos
réquisitions et votre brutalité
policière!
Vous, qui êtes le donneur d'ordre,
assumez votre responsabilité dans
l'escalade de la violence.
Nous serons mobilisés jusqu'au
retrait de votre réforme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin, ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Madame la
présidente, monsieur le député,
comme vous, je voudrais avoir un
mot pour ces 394 gendarmes et
policiers blessés.
Applaudissements et huées
...
Je vous remercie d'avoir...
Je vous remercie d'avoir souligné
leur courage et j'ai une pensée
particulière pour ce CRS qui, ce
matin, a une fracture ouverte de
la malléole et qui, au moment où
nous parlons, est sur la table
d'opération.
J'irai lui rendre visite à la
demande du président de la
République et de la Première
ministre.
J'irai porter le soutien unanime
de la représentation nationale.
Les policiers et les gendarmes
font face à 1500 opérations non
déclarées.
Je veux d'ailleurs dire
aujourd'hui qu'il n'est pas dans
l'Etat de droit de s'en prendre à
des bâtiments publics, de saccager
des mairies, de mettre le feu à
des préfectures, de jeter des
cocktails Molotov sur les
gendarmes sur les policiers et je
vous remercie de soutenir ces
personnes qui sont de véritables
ouvriers de la sécurité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Il vous reste 3 secondes.
Un peu de silence, s'il vous
plaît!
Allez-y, mon cher collègue.
- Andy Kerbrat: Vous comparez des
dégradations aux bâtiments à des
dégradations sexistes et
sexuelles!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Gérald Darmanin: Je vous
remercie...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Un peu de
silence, s'il vous plaît!
- Gérald Darmanin: Je voudrais ici
vous rappeler que, s'agissant des
enquêtes de l'IGPN, elles sont
conduites sous les procureurs de
la République et chacun devrait
respecter la justice.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Contestations
Est-ce que vous pourriez faire
silence pour que le prochain
orateur puisse s'exprimer?
La parole est à madame Graziella
Melchior pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Graziella Melchior: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Pap Ndiaye, ministre de
l'Education nationale et de la
Jeunesse.
Depuis hier et jusqu'à mercredi,
536.000 lycéens et lycéennes
passent leurs épreuves de
spécialité.
Dans ma région, en Bretagne, ce
sont 26.000 candidates et
candidats qui vont devoir
plancher.
Histoire-géographie, géopolitique,
sciences politiques, littérature
et philosophie, physique-chimie,
ces matières de spécialité qu'ils
ont choisies comptent pour un
tiers des résultats du bac et
seront pour la première fois prise
en compte dans Parcoursup.
Depuis la réforme du baccalauréat
que nous avons votée en 2019, ces
épreuves ont été supprimées du
fait de la crise Covid en 2021.
Pour la même raison, elles ont été
reportées au mois de mai en 2022,
retirant leur intérêt qui était de
départager les candidats dans
Parcoursup.
En tant que professeure en IUT, je
sais que les notes de ces examens
permettront de disposer d'un moyen
d'avoir le niveau d'un élève.
Cela limite le biais discriminant
qui pouvait exister auparavant.
Malgré le contexte social
difficile, il était important que
ces examens se tiennent.
Je remercie l'ensemble de la
communauté éducative de s'être
engagée pour la réussite des
élèves et je suis convaincue
qu'aujourd'hui encore, elle saura
prendre ses responsabilités.
Nous l'avons vu hier, dans
l'ensemble, la journée s'est bien
passée.
Pouvez-vous nous indiquer ce que
le gouvernement a mis en place
pour permettre à toutes les
lycéennes et à tous les lycéens de
passer leurs examens dans des
conditions sereines depuis hier et
jusqu'à demain?
Des craintes ont été évoquées
concernant un éventuel blocage de
la correction des copies dans le
cadre de la mobilisation sociale.
Pouvez-vous nous dire ce que vous
avez souhaité afin que les notes
de ces épreuves, si importantes
pour nos jeunes, soient bien
prises en compte?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Pap Ndiaye, ministre de
l'Education nationale et de la
Jeunesse.
- Pap Ndiaye: Madame la députée,
vous l'avez dit, pour la première
fois, les résultats des deux
épreuves de spécialité seront pris
en compte dans la procédure
Parcoursup.
C'est important, puisque les
établissements supérieurs auront
des résultats normés à l'échelle
nationale, indépendants des
variations selon les lycées, liées
aux contrôles continus et ils s'en
réjouissent.
Les programmes étaient adaptés.
Nous allons voir ce qu'il y a à
ajuster pour la session 2024, mais
je tiens d'ores et déjà à saluer
l'organisation générale du
baccalauréat qui se déroule sans
faillir jusqu'à présent.
Tous les élèves ont pu entrer.
Il n'y a pas eu de blocage.
Il n'y a pas eu de difficultés de
surveillance.
Nous n'attendons pas de
difficultés particulières en ce
qui concerne la correction d'ici
au 10 avril.
Désormais, les élèves vont pouvoir
se consacrer à la préparation au
grand oral et à l'épreuve de
philosophie qui interviendront à
la mi-juin.
Leur avenir ne reposera plus comme
avant sur une semaine cruciale au
mois de juin, mais sur un
équilibre entre le contrôle
continu et des épreuves finales
comme celles qu'ils sont en train
de passer à l'heure actuelle.
Encore une fois, nous tirerons le
bilan, mais jusqu'à présent, nous
avons tout lieu de nous féliciter
de l'organisation générale des
épreuves.
Cela se fait en bonne coordination
avec, en cas de blocage éventuel,
les services des préfectures, des
forces de l'ordre, qui n'ont pas
été mobilisés.
Nous sommes prêts à agir en cas de
blocage.
Pour l'instant, la situation est
tout à fait satisfaisante et nous
avons tout lieu de nous en
féliciter.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Pierre
Meurin pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Pierre Meurin: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la Première ministre,
enfin, pour le moment, pendant que
vous essorez les Français avec une
réforme injuste et brutale, les
super-profiteurs peuvent compter
sur votre complaisance coupable.
Nous disposons enfin du rapport de
l'Inspection Générale des Finances
sur les concessions autoroutières
et son contenu spectaculaire
explique peut-être que vous l'ayez
piteusement rangé dans un placard
depuis 2021.
Une telle escroquerie pourrait
être classée au patrimoine du
grand banditisme d'Etat.
Les autoroutes françaises, que
l'Etat a parfaitement su gérer
jusqu'en 2005, ont été vendues à
ces grandes entreprises pour un
prix de cession minorée de 8
millions d'euros.
En 2015, votre implication dans
cette fraude est directe.
Quand vous étiez socialistes, avec
Emmanuel Macron, vous avez mis en
oeuvre avec ces sociétés un plan
de relance en leur faisant cadeau
de trois ans supplémentaires.
Cela a permis de faire monter le
taux de rentabilité des
actionnaires jusqu'à 12% et ce
taux a été négocié par Alexis
Kohler et par vous-même.
Résultat: 15 millions d'euros de
dividendes supplémentaires pour
les actionnaires.
Vous avez même négocié avec votre
ancien employeur.
Vous avez dirigé le service des
concessions chez Eiffage, cela
vous plaçant personnellement dans
une situation de conflit
d'intérêts.
Ce scandale indique une réalité:
vous travaillez pour les
super-profiteurs et contre les
Français qui paient chaque jour
leur péage.
Les trois solutions pour vous
rattraper existent toutefois.
D'abord, une fin anticipée des
concessions en 2026, une baisse du
prix des péages de 60% dès 2022,
le prélèvement par l'Etat de 64%
des bénéfices de ces sociétés,
soit un total de 22,5 milliards
d'euros d'ici 2026.
Quel est donc votre solution?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Le
Maire, ministre de l'Economie et
des Finances.
- Bruno Le Maire: Madame la
présidente, monsieur le député,
visiblement, vous confondez les
millions et les milliards.
Ce n'est pas très rassurant pour
vos fonctions de parlementaires.
Heureusement que ce n'est pas vous
qui exercez le pouvoir dans notre
pays.
Nous avons rendu publics 15
rapports.
Nous avons, avec le ministre des
Transports, depuis deux ans, fait
en sorte que les tarifs
autoroutiers, notamment en 2022,
augmentent moins que l'inflation.
Je vous invite à participer à la
commission qui aura lieu demain, à
laquelle nous participons avec le
ministre des Transports.
Nous répondrons à toutes les
questions sur ce sujet en toute
transparence pour expliquer notre
politique sur les autoroutes.
Je voudrais insister sur la
solution alternative que votre
présidente propose en matière
d'autoroutes.
Vous avez proposé, madame Le Pen,
la nationalisation des autoroutes
françaises.
Ca ne coûte pas 40 à 50 millions,
ça coûte 40 à 50 milliards d'euros
à l'Etat français.
C'est la double peine, la peine
pour le contribuable quand on
devra augmenter les impôts pour
rembourser les 40 à 50 milliards,
et c'est la peine pour le climat
car nous avons mieux à faire
qu'investir dans les autoroutes.
Nous voulons investir dans la
décarbonation de notre industrie
et dans le trafic ferroviaire.
Vous regardez le passé, nous
regardons le futur.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
S'il vous plaît!
La parole est à madame la
présidente Cyrielle Chatelain pour
le groupe écologiste.
- Cyrielle Chatelain: Madame la
Première ministre, partout se
multiplient les vidéos d'une
violence inouïe.
On y voit des manifestants
matraqués, chargés sans sommation
claire, exposés à des jets de gaz
lacrymogènes quand ce ne sont pas
pire.
Parfois, ils sont genoux à terre
contre un mur.
Les situations de menaces se
multiplient.
On encercle, on contrôle, on
intimide.
Le 14 mars, quatre étudiantes à
Nantes ont porté plainte pour des
agressions sexuelles par des
policiers.
On constate aussi le retour des
brigades motorisées.
On constate que, pour la seule
nuit de jeudi à Paris, 292
personnes ont été placées en garde
à vue.
97% de ces arrestations ont été
classées sans suite.
Votre gouvernement se comporte
comme un gouvernement assiégé.
Les Français vous font-ils peur?
Madame la Première ministre,
préférez-vous une France pétrifiée
à une France engagée?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Madame la Première ministre, vous
avez la parole.
- Elisabeth Borne: Madame la
députée, depuis des mois, avec le
ministre du Travail, nous avons
bâti un compromis sur la réforme
des retraites dans le respect de
nos institutions.
Dès l'automne, des concertations
ont été menées avec les
organisations syndicales et
patronales et les groupes
parlementaires.
Elles nous ont permis d'élaborer
notre projet, qui était présenté
aux Français et aux parlementaires
en janvier.
Le compromis, nous l'avons ensuite
construit pendant 175 heures de
débat au Parlement et lors de la
commission mixte paritaire.
Avec les députés de la majorité et
d'opposition, nous avons débattu
et enrichi le texte.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
nous n'avons jamais été aussi loin
dans la construction d'un
compromis, mais le compromis,
madame la présidente Chatelain,
cela demande du courage, tout
comme certaines réformes demandent
de la responsabilité pour agir.
Agir pour sauver notre système de
retraite par répartition, pour
revaloriser les petites pensions,
pour permettre à ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt de
partir plus tôt et pour prendre en
compte les carrières hachées,
c'est ça que nous avons construit
avec tous ceux qui veulent sauver
notre système de retraite par
répartition.
Lorsque certains choisissent la
stratégie du chaos, des cris, des
injures, comment pouvez-vous
ensuite nous reprocher que ce
texte n'ait pas pu être examiné
jusqu'à son terme et comment
osez-vous nous le reprocher et
nous reprocher la violence dans la
rue?
Face à ces violences, je veux à
nouveau rendre hommage à nos
forces de l'ordre qui assurent la
sécurité des manifestations.
Je le redis, ils ont un devoir
d'exemplarité et ils en sont
conscients.
Tout signalement est examiné.
Malgré les violences, malgré les
outrages, malgré l'obstruction,
les mois de concertation et de
dialogue ont permis d'aboutir à un
texte équilibré, porteur de
progrès pour les Français.
Plus que jamais, je suis
convaincue que c'est par le
dialogue, par la recherche de
compromis que nous apporterons des
solutions aux Français.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Madame la présidente?
- Cyrielle Chatelain: Le seul
compromis que vous avez fait, a
priori, c'est avec votre
conscience.
Vous mentez sans honte à
l'Assemblée nationale.
Vous encerclez les Français et
vous leur mentez sans honte.
Vous cherchez à rendre la rue
silencieuse, mais que vous
faudra-t-il pour les écouter?
Des blessés?
Des morts?
Je vous demande solennellement de
ne pas faire le jeu de la
répression.
Pour cela, il n'y a qu'une
solution: le retrait de cette
réforme.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Faure pour le groupe socialiste.
- Olivier Faure: Madame la
Première ministre, par son
obstination, le président a
conduit le pays dans une impasse
sociale, mais aussi politique.
Vous n'avez ni majorité populaire,
ni majorité à l'Assemblée, comme
vous l'avez vous-même avoué en
reconnaissant à la télévision que
le compte n'y était pas.
Vous êtes en train de fracturer
notre pays et la seule unité que
vous réalisez, c'est contre vous.
Hier, 80% des sondés déclaraient
souhaiter que votre gouvernement
tombe.
Votre mépris et votre brutalité
entraînent en écho des
manifestations auxquelles
participent de très nombreux
jeunes, le retour des pelotons
voltigeurs, la présence d'unités
de police qui ne sont pas formées
au maintien de l'ordre, et cela
devrait tous nous inquiéter.
Ce sont des enfants qui
manifestent et qui font face à des
méthodes qui ont radicalement
changé depuis une semaine.
Qu'attendez-vous?
Attendez-vous un drame?
Vous jouez avec le feu.
Cette colère ne s'arrêtera pas.
Vous ne pouvez pas attendre que
cela passe.
Ca ne passera pas.
Cette colère, c'est celle du monde
du travail, les "premiers de
corvée" que vous avez vous-même
célébrés pendant la crise
sanitaire.
Ils demandent maintenant à être
respectés et, tous ici, nous nous
battrons pour qu'ils le soient
effectivement.
Que valent vos grands discours sur
la "valeur travail" quand vous ne
donnez aucune valeur au travail?
Pour sortir du blocage, vous
n'avez plus d'autre choix que le
retrait ou le retour au jugement
du peuple.
Le président ne veut ni
remaniement, ni référendum, il ne
reste que le retrait.
Ce que Jacques Chirac avait
compris, vous devez le faire
maintenant.
On ne gouverne jamais...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Monsieur le
député, à qui allez vous faire
croire que le Parti Socialiste,
s'il revenait au pouvoir,
reviendrait sur cette réforme?
A personne.
Est-ce qu'en 1997, le Parti
Socialiste est revenu sur la
réforme de 1993?
Jamais.
Nous avons renforcé la réforme en
votant un allongement de la durée
de cotisation.
Vous avez voté le passage à 43
ans.
Vous l'avez voté et vous ne
l'assumez pas.
C'est grâce à la loi de Marisol
Touraine que les Français doivent
travailler plus longtemps.
Vous vous offusquez du recours au
49.3.
Vous l'avez justifié en 2015.
Vous l'avez justifié en 2016,
aussi, sur la loi travail.
Vous parlez des travailleurs et
les conditions de travail, je me
souviens de vous entrain de
justifier le 49.3 pour saboter la
loi El Khomri.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Anne
Genetet pour le groupe
Renaissance.
Brouhaha
Chut!
S'il vous plaît!
On écoute madame Genetet.
- Anne Genetet: Merci.
Chers collègues, ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères.
On va sortir un peu de nos
frontières.
Le 7 mars dernier, la Géorgie
s'embrasait.
Des milliers de manifestants
réclamaient le retrait de la loi
dite "sur les agents étrangers",
triste réplique d'une loi
promulguée il y a 10 ans en Russie
dont l'objectif à peine masqué
était de museler médias,
opposition et ONG.
Le 7 mars dernier, la Géorgie
s'embrasait face à cette énième
marque d'influence, voire
d'ingérence russe, dans les
affaires du pays.
Une présence étrangère
matérialisée par l'occupation
d'une partie du territoire
géorgien depuis 2008 qui s'est
renforcée avec l'installation de
populations russes qui fuient la
conscription et la guerre.
Face aux tentatives de mainmise
russe,
la Géorgie l'a affirmé quelques
jours à peine après la déclaration
de guerre à l'Ukraine lorsqu'elle
a présenté une demande d'adhésion.
A l'UE.
Au mois de juin, cette demande a
été reconnue conformément à l'avis
européen.
Ce projet doit avancer.
A cet égard, alors que la
Commission européenne se
prononcera prochainement sur les
progrès accomplis par le pays pour
répondre aux priorités en matière
de réformes recensées, où en est
la Géorgie?
La population géorgienne n'a de
cesse de nous rappeler son
attachement à l'Union Européenne
et nos pays entretiennent des
relations amicales anciennes.
Quel rôle et quelles initiatives
pourraient être prises par la
France pour accompagner la Géorgie
dans cette voie?
Comment l'accompagner dans la
résolution de la question de la
polarisation politique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Catherine
Colonna, ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères.
- Catherine Colonna: Madame la
députée, le projet de loi sur les
agents de l'étranger que vous avez
évoqué
était évidemment incompatibles
avec les valeurs de l'Union
Européenne.
La Géorgie aspire à la rejoindre.
Le peuple géorgien a démontré son
attachement profond à l'Union
Européenne de façon pacifique.
Les messages que nous avons passés
avec les autres Etats européens
ont contribué à conduire le
Parlement géorgien à retirer ce
projet de loi.
C'est chose faite.
Il s'agit évidemment d'une
décision salutaire qui doit
conduire désormais la Géorgie à
poursuivre sans plus tarder les
réformes qui sont nécessaires pour
renforcer l'Etat de droit.
Je l'ai dit à plusieurs reprises,
à sa présidente que j'ai reçue il
y a une quinzaine de jours, le
statut de candidat à l'Union
Européenne passe par de profondes
réformes.
L'aspiration des Géorgiens est
d'avoir plus d'Etat de droit, plus
de libertés pour les médias et
pour les ONG, en un mot, plus de
ces valeurs qui sont celles de
l'Europe.
Cette aspiration du peuple
géorgien, il nous revient de la
préserver face aux tentatives de
déstabilisation, nous en avons vu
quelques-unes.
Je voudrais rappeler la présence
illégale de troupes russes en
Géorgie comme en Moldavie.
Je l'ai d'ailleurs souligné hier à
mon arrivée à Bruxelles à la
réunion des 27 ministres des
Affaires étrangères de l'Union
Européenne.
La France continuera à accompagner
la Géorgie sur le chemin des
réformes et elle doit savoir
pouvoir compter sur notre amitié,
sur notre vigilance également et
sur notre soutien pour parvenir à
intégrer l'Union Européenne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Caroline Parmentier pour
le Rassemblement National.
- Caroline Parmentier: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à la
ministre de la Culture.
Madame la ministre, je me suis
rendue au palais de Tokyo pour
dénoncer un tableau qui présente
aux yeux de tous une scène de
pédocriminalité.
Ce tableau représente un enfant à
genoux, ligoté les mains dans le
dos, forcé à une fellation par un
adulte.
Rien ne justifie l'exposition
d'une telle oeuvre, pas même le
prétexte de la dénonciation de
crimes de guerre.
Ce tableau à caractère ouvertement
pédopornographique est exposé dans
la sphère publique sans
interdiction aux mineurs depuis le
17 février, dans un musée du 16e
arrondissement.
Rappelons que nous-mêmes et
d'autres associations de
protections de l'enfance, si nous
n'avions pas dénoncé l'exposition
des dessins de Bastien Vivès, il
aurait été exposé à Angoulême.
Son exposition a été annulée.
Il est désormais sous le coup
d'une enquête de la brigade des
mineurs pour diffusion d'images
pédopornographiques.
Comme l'a rappelé l'association
Innocence en danger, qui a demandé
le retrait de la toile de Miriam
Cahn, ce tableau nuit à nos
valeurs communes et au combat pour
la protection de l'enfance.
En tant que membre de la
commission des Affaires
culturelles, en tant que membre de
la délégation aux droits des
enfants, mais surtout en tant que
femme et en tant que mère, je vous
demande si l'exposition de ce
genre de tableau sera l'un des
marqueurs de votre mandat, un
glissement vers la démocratisation
et l'acceptation de ce type
d'oeuvre et si ce n'est pas le
cas, je vous demande
solennellement quand ce tableau va
être décroché.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Rima Abdul
Malak.
- Rima Abdul Malak: Madame la
députée, ne mélangeons pas tout.
Le combat pour la protection de
l'enfance et contre toutes les
formes de violence, je le mène
collectivement du côté du
gouvernement tous les jours.
Ce tableau, de quoi s'agit-il?
C'est un tableau d'une artiste
suisse.
C'est une artiste de 73 ans qui,
depuis 40 ans, documente et
dénonce les horreurs de la guerre.
C'est son intention.
Vous êtes allée faire votre coup
de com' et filmer ce tableau, mais
est-ce que vous avez vu l'ensemble
de l'exposition?
Est-ce que vous avez échangé avec
les médiateurs?
Est-ce que vous avez lu les
explications?
On ne peut pas sortir une oeuvre
de son contexte.
L'intention de l'artiste est
diamétralement opposée à
l'interprétation que vous en
faites.
Pour elle, c'est une dénonciation
des crimes de guerre.
Ce ne sont pas des enfants qui
sont représentés.
Ce tableau traite de la façon dont
la sexualité est utilisée comme
arme de guerre, comme crime contre
l'humanité.
Le contraste entre les deux corps
figure la puissance corporelle de
l'oppresseur et la fragilité de
l'opprimé.
La répétition des images de
violence dans les guerres vise à
dénoncer.
Oui, l'art peut choquer, il peut
questionner, il peut parfois
susciter du malaise, voire du
dégoût, car l'art n'est pas
consensuel.
La liberté d'expression et de
création est garantie par la loi.
Vous avez toute liberté
d'interpréter l'oeuvre comme vous
le voulez.
Ce n'est ni à une ministre, ni à
une parlementaire de qualifier une
infraction pénale.
C'est le rôle de la justice.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît!
Je vous remercie.
- Caroline Parmentier: Il suffit
donc que l'artiste décrète que ce
n'est pas un enfant alors que
c'est clairement un enfant pour
qu'il soit dédouané?
En réalité, peu importe les
allégations ou les intentions de
l'artiste, elles ne permettent pas
d'échapper à la qualification
pénale dans la mesure où le plus
grand nombre reconnaît la
représentation d'un enfant dans
cette figure agenouillée et
violée.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
- Caroline Parmentier: Vous
devriez avoir honte.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole...
Chut!
S'il vous plaît!
La parole est à monsieur le
président Bertrand Pancher.
- Bertrand Pancher: Madame la
Première ministre, quand
allez-vous retirer la réforme des
retraites voulue par Emmanuel
Macron?
Prenez-vous la mesure du péril que
traverse notre pays?
Les Français sont inquiets et en
colère.
Vous aviez fait le pari que la
situation se calmerait une fois la
réforme passée.
Elle devient incontrôlable.
Le résultat du vote de la motion
de censure transpartisane est un
séisme politique.
Merci à ceux qui l'ont
accompagnée.
Certes, il a manqué quelques voix,
mais qui aurait pu parier sur un
résultat si étriqué?
Mesurez-vous l'opposition à cette
réforme?
L'opposition des organisations
syndicales, de l'Assemblée, des
Français pour qui la réforme est
injuste et inefficace.
Faute d'avoir répondu aux
manifestations pacifiques d'une
ampleur inédite, nous assistons à
une radicalisation du mouvement.
Faute d'écoute et de véritables
débats, le chaos risque d'emporter
notre pays.
Notre démocratie est en danger.
Nous ne voulons pas du chaos.
Nous vous faisons des
propositions.
A travers vous, c'est au président
Macron que les parlementaires du
groupe LIOT s'adressent.
Il est encore temps d'éteindre
l'incendie qu'il a déclenché.
Nous lui demandons de ne pas
promulguer ce projet de loi.
Dans le cas contraire, il devra
donner la parole à nos concitoyens
par un référendum.
Ce n'est malheureusement pas le
choix qu'il semble faire.
Cette loi retirée, Emmanuel Macron
devra retrouver le chemin de la
concorde à travers la consultation
des forces politiques, sociales
via des groupes parlementaires et
des élus locaux.
Nous devrons déterminer enfin
ensemble des grandes réformes à
mener pour notre pays.
Changez de méthode et de cap.
Nous ne pouvons pas continuer
ainsi pendant quatre ans.
Tout le monde le sait.
Madame la Première ministre,
êtes-vous prêts à cela?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le président, hier, le
texte construit par les
parlementaires, après plusieurs
semaines de débats et un accord en
commission mixte paritaire, a
achevé son parcours législatif.
Ce texte de compromis garantit
l'avenir de nos retraites.
Vous aurez beau dire l'inverse,
monsieur le président, crier à
l'absence de dialogue, vous
assurer ainsi quelques heures de
gloire, mais la réalité est
pourtant bien celle-ci.
Le texte sur lequel j'ai engagé ma
responsabilité est celui d'un
compromis parlementaire.
Cette réforme est une réforme pour
assurer l'avenir de notre système
de retraite par répartition.
Nous avons travaillé avec des
parlementaires sur tous les bancs
à la rendre plus juste.
Avec votre groupe, le groupe LIOT,
nous avons travaillé et trouver
des compromis, notamment pour
l'application de la réforme dans
les outre-mer.
Je suis bien consciente des
efforts que demande cette réforme.
Je suis bien consciente de
l'inquiétude qu'elle peut
susciter, et je connais les
revendications des mouvements
sociaux.
C'est pourquoi, avec mon
gouvernement, avec les
parlementaires qui veulent agir
pour nos concitoyens, avec les
territoires et nos élus locaux,
avec les partenaires sociaux, nous
voulons répondre aux inquiétudes
des Français, les rassembler et
apporter des solutions efficaces
et concrètes.
Nous devons répondre aux
interrogations que ce projet de
réforme des retraites a mises en
lumière, sur notre projet, sur
l'égalité des chances, sur notre
offre de perspectives
professionnelles.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Clémence
Guetté.
- Clémence Guetté: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le ministre de la
Transition écologique, cette
semaine est celle de la censure
populaire, censure de vos
agissements antidémocratiques
permis par la Ve République,
censure aussi de votre action
anti-écologique encouragée par le
capitalisme.
Le rapport du GIEC est sorti hier
et nous alerte très clairement.
75% des habitants de cette planète
pourraient souffrir de vagues de
chaleur meurtrières à l'horizon
2100.
Partout dans le monde, le rythme
normal des précipitations et des
saisons laissent place à un
enchaînement d'événements
climatiques extrêmes.
En France, après des étés sans
pluie, une sécheresse hivernale a
mis le niveau des nappes au plus
bas.
Cela rend donc obsolète les
fameuses bassines pas encore
construites mais dont vous voulez
pourtant recouvrir le pays.
Ce week-end, nous serons des
milliers dans la Vienne et les
Deux-Sèvres pour défendre le droit
à l'eau et pour dire non aux
méga-bassines de substitution.
Contre un modèle insensé que vous
voulez imposer en dépit de toutes
les alertes, nous sommes le front
de la résistance.
Ecoutez les hydrologues, les
agronomes, les paysans qui vous
disent qu'il faut permettre le
remplissage des nappes
phréatiques, et empêcher
l'accaparement de l'eau au profit
d'une minorité, l'explosion de son
prix pour tous.
En effet, aujourd'hui, deux
chemins s'ouvrent devant nous:
l'adaptation ou la prédation, le
partage ou le pillage,
l'agriculture vivrière ou la
grosse industrie meurtrière.
Vous devez rendre des comptes au
peuple sur ce choix.
Comme pour les retraites, vous
optez pour la brutalité.
Du droit à l'eau au droit de
grève, vous criminalisez les
Français qui résistent en espérant
dissimuler votre propre inaction
climatique et vos attaques
antisociales.
Monsieur le ministre, le peuple ne
veut ni des bassines, ni de votre
monde.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre,
mesdames et messieurs les députés,
madame la députée, sécheresse
hivernale, rapport du GIEC...
Avec le dérèglement climatique,
nous devrons nous préparer à avoir
entre 10 et 40% d'eau en moins.
Il n'y a pas d'agriculture sans
eau.
L'hypocrisie qui consisterait à
déporter notre empreinte en eau
ailleurs avec des conditions qui
empêcheraient les agriculteurs de
produire n'est ni responsable, ni
courageuse.
La meilleure retenue, c'est la
nappe phréatique.
La meilleure solution, c'est la
sobriété, mais il y a autant de
situations qu'il y a de
territoires.
Un protocole a été validé par la
majorité.
Dans cette histoire, qui hystérise
le débat?
Vous êtes en train de donner des
leçons dans un contexte où la
dernière manifestation a débouché
sur 61 gendarmes blessés par des
boules de pétanque, visés par des
tirs de mortier et des jets de
pierre.
Vous dressez les Français les uns
contre les autres.
Vous radicalisez, vous simplifiez
tout à l'extrême, en faisant comme
si tout était noir et blanc et en
prenant le pari du chaos, du
désordre et de la menace tous
azimuts.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Philippe
Pradal.
- Philippe Pradal: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Cette question s'adresse à madame
la secrétaire d'Etat auprès du
ministre des Armées chargée des
Anciens combattants et de la
Mémoire.
Madame la secrétaire d'Etat, il y
a quasiment 69 ans jour pour jour,
regroupés dans la cuvette
de Dien Bien Phu,
les troupes françaises
cessaient le combat.
Fidèles aux mots du
commandant-en-chef:
"Il faut laisser le feu
mourir de lui-même,
mais ne pas capituler, ne pas
lever le drapeau blanc."
De nombreux militaires français
avaient perdu la vie dans un combat
au cours duquel le courage des
deux côtés devait conduire au
respect réciproque, gravant leurs
souvenirs et leur mémoire.
Les conditions de départ des
troupes françaises n'ont pas
permis de donner une sépulture
digne et descente à tous ceux qui
ont donné leur vie à une terre que
beaucoup d'entre eux aimaient
profondément.
Les années qui ont passé nous ont
permis de parcourir avec la
République socialiste du Viêtnam
un chemin conduisant à marquer en
2023 le double anniversaire de nos
relations diplomatiques et de
notre partenariat stratégique.
Edouard Philippe s'était rendu sur
les sites mémoriaux sur place pour
délivrer un message d'admiration,
de respect et de fierté.
Le développement de la zone
conduit aujourd'hui à un projet
d'extension de l'aéroport.
Ces travaux pourraient conduire à
profaner une centaine de
dépouilles de soldats ayant
combattu sur ce site.
Le gouvernement français
envisage-t-il une action
permettant de préserver les
tombes, souvent sommaires, de ces
soldats qui ont donné de leur vie
sur ordre du gouvernement français
et de leur chef?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Patricia Mirallès.
- Patricia Mirallès: Je vous
remercie pour cette question qui
va me permettre de rétablir les
faits et d'éteindre les polémiques
que certains voudraient lancer en
méconnaissance des principes qui
ont toujours guidé l'action de
l'Etat en la matière.
La France a une obligation de
sépulture perpétuelle pour tout
ceux qui sont morts pour elle.
Elle est inscrite dans la loi de
la Première Guerre mondiale, sauf
bien entendu lorsque les familles
souhaitent récupérer les corps.
Dans le cas particulier du
Viêtnam, une doctrine s'est forgée
en accord avec le gouvernement
vietnamien et avec les
associations de combattants.
Les corps doivent être rapatriés
en métropole, dans la nécropole du
mémorial des guerres à Fréjus.
Les associations de combattants
m'ont confirmé, encore la semaine
dernière, qu'elles ne souhaitaient
pas déroger à cette règle, bien
établies pour la guerre
d'Indochine.
Cela nécessite dans un premier
temps d'organiser avec les
autorités vietnamiennes les
modalités d'information de
l'ambassade et de la conservation
des corps lors de leurs
découvertes.
Je sais que les autorités
vietnamiennes sont
particulièrement vigilantes et
respectueuses sur ce point.
Dans un second temps, il convient
d'organiser les modalités de
rapatriement en mettant à jour un
accord franco- vietnamien qui date
de 1986, relatif au rapatriement
des corps de militaires français
au Viêtnam.
La France n'oublie aucun de ses
combattants, quel que soit le
nombre d'années ou des kilomètres
qui nous sépare de leur sacrifice.
C'est dans cet esprit que je serai
présente le 8 juin pour la journée
nationale d'hommage aux morts pour
la France en Indochine, à la
nécropole du mémorial national de
Fréjus.
Les dépouilles seront retrouvées à
Dien Bien Phu ou ailleurs au
Viêtnam retrouveront leurs frères
d'armes qui sont déjà au mémorial.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Charles
Fournier.
- Charles Fournier: Madame la
présidente, mes chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse à la
Première ministre en charge de la
planification écologique.
Après huit ans de travaux, le GIEC
a publié hier son rapport, et il
est formel: les politiques
actuellement en oeuvre y compris
en France nous mènent à un
réchauffement de deux degrés à
l'horizon de 2100.
Chaque fraction de degré
supplémentaire est une menace pour
les écosystèmes.
Les risques s'intensifient et les
plus vulnérables en payent déjà le
prix.
Il y a urgence à agir.
Aucune réaction de la part du
président de la République.
Aucune réaction de votre part
suite à la publication du rapport
du GIEC.
Nous l'avons dit et nous l'avons
répété, retraite et climat, même
combat.
Derrière la réforme des retraites
se cache les stigmates du tout
productivisme qui vous guide
aveuglement.
Travailler plus pour produire et
consommer toujours plus.
C'est aussi pour cela que les
jeunes sont dans la rue.
La France se croit une bonne élève
climatique, mais vous êtes dans le
même déni que Dédale, homme de
tous les talents, dont
l'inventivité et l'arrogance lui
font croire que la technique va
pouvoir réparer les problèmes
qu'il a créés.
Vous connaissez la suite.
Vous avez toujours une solution
technique, une solution numérique.
A la décarbonation, vous répondez
avec des EPR.
Aux problèmes de sécheresse, des
méga-bassines.
Si on risque une France à
plus de 4 degrés, quel est votre
plan d'urgence pour la transition
écologique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Agnès Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député, le rapport du
GIEC confirme l'extrême urgence à
agir pour atteindre les objectifs
des Accords de Paris.
Vous avez raison.
Monsieur le député, je sais que
nous nous retrouvons sur ce
constat et la nécessité de prendre
en main cette course
contre-la-montre.
Là où vous êtes dans
l'atermoiement, nous sommes dans
l'action.
C'est cette majorité et ce
gouvernement qui ont doublé la
vitesse de baisse des gaz à effet
de serre lors des précédents
quinquennats.
C'est cette majorité et ce
gouvernement qui ont porté,
lorsqu'ils avaient la présidence
française, le texte le plus
ambitieux en matière climatique
internationale, qui est le paquet
climat.
C'est ce gouvernement et cette
Première ministre qui ont
promulgué une loi sur
l'accélération de l'énergie
renouvelable que vous n'avez pas
votée.
C'est ce gouvernement qui porte un
projet de loi sur le nucléaire
énergie que le GIEC lui-même
indique comme étant utile à la
lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique.
Si vous alliez lire dans le détail
les rapports du GIEC...
Vous ne le faites pas.
Vous êtes dans le coup d'éclat.
j'invite l'ensemble des députés de
cet hémicycle à prendre le destin
climatique de la France en main.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Stéphane
Delautrette.
- Stéphane Delautrette: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Est-ce qu'il faut reculer l'âge de
la retraite qui est aujourd'hui à
62 ans?
Je ne crois pas.
Aujourd'hui, on est peu qualifié,
on vit dans une région qui est en
difficulté industrielle, on est
soi-même en difficulté, on a une
carrière fracturée, donc bon
courage pour arriver à 62 ans.
C'est ça, la réalité de notre
pays.
Vous êtes dans le mépris du
dialogue social.
Pire encore, dans le mépris des
Françaises et des Français qui se
sont jusque-là mobilisés
pacifiquement par millions dans
des cortèges.
C'était sans compter sur votre
ultime recours au 49.3 qui a
ouvert une nouvelle séquence, à
laquelle vous ne répondez pas, si
ce n'est par la répression, au
risque d'embraser le mouvement.
Vous portez là une lourde
responsabilité sur vos épaules.
Madame la Première ministre,
allez-vous enfin entendre raison?
Allez-vous, oui ou non, retirez
votre loi qui ne convainc plus
personne?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, la loi telle
qu'elle a été adoptée par le
Parlement après le rejet des
motions de censure est une loi qui
vient après quatre mois de
contestation et 175 heures de
débats, ici.
Le seul mépris pour le Parlement,
c'est lorsqu'on organise une
obstruction systématique,
lorsqu'on dépose 20.000
amendements juste pour priver le
Parlement de sa capacité à
débattre.
Ca n'a pas été le cas au Sénat.
Ca a permis un examen complet de
la loi.
Cette loi va permettre de
valoriser les petites retraites,
ça va permettre de mieux prendre
en compte la pénibilité, de mieux
accompagner les carrières longues,
de maintenir l'emploi des seniors.
N'êtes-vous pas d'accord avec ça?
Il faut que notre système de
retraite soit préservé, protégé.
Il est utile à ceux qui sont les
plus fragiles.
C'est à eux que nous pensons.
- Stéphane Delautrette: Monsieur
le ministre, le passage en force
n'est pas la solution.
Nous préférons la démocratie.
Si vous croyez à ce que vous
dites, à défaut d'entendre la
représentation nationale, laissez
les Françaises et les Français
décider par la voix d'un
référendum.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Alexandre Portier.
- Alexandre Portier: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Education
nationale.
Monsieur le ministre, je ne
prendrai qu'un exemple.
Le chiffre, c'est 1500 postes
d'enseignants que vous allez
supprimer à la rentrée prochaine,
à l'heure où nos classes sont déjà
les plus surchargées de toute
l'Europe.
L'exemple, c'est l'école d'un
petit village dont je suis le
député, où la commune a investi
plus de 150.000 euros ces
dernières années.
Une école où des générations
entières de famille se sont
succédées et une école surtout,
aux résultats que l'on envierait
partout en France.
Nous avons même un champion de
lecture qui portera nos couleurs
au niveau départemental.
C'est une vraie fierté pour tous
au village.
Cette école n'a cette année que
neuf élèves.
On s'empresse de la fermer.
Dans quatre ans, elle sera revenu
à 15 élèves.
Ces effectifs ne vont cesser de
remonter.
Au lieu de proposer des pistes
pour soutenir l'école pendant ce
creux, on s'empresse de faire une
croix dessus.
C'est un non-sens absolu.
Vous fermez les classes, mais sans
jamais nous dire combien, au
total.
On en annonce des centaines, à la
ville comme à la campagne, dans
des petits villages, mais aussi à
Paris.
Je vous pose la question,
dites-nous clairement combien de
classes vous allez fermer à la
rentrée, partout en France, et
pour le Haut Beaujolais.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député, votre question
s'inscrit dans un contexte qui est
celui d'une baisse très importante
des effectifs scolaires à
l'échelle du pays, dont -3000
élèves dans votre département, à
la rentrée 2023.
Vous noterez que ces baisses
d'effectifs coïncident avec des
baisses de postes, contrairement à
certaines périodes, comme entre
2007 et 2012, où il y avait une
croissance des effectifs
scolaires.
Cela est sans doute secondaire.
J'en reviens à mon point
principal.
Nous devons, et je vous concède ce
point, du côté du ministère de
l'Education nationale, faire mieux
de manière à ce que les communes,
en particulier celle dont vous
parlez, soient mieux aménagées
côté budget dans une perspective
longue.
Les enfants qui naissent
aujourd'hui sont les enfants qui
seront scolarisés dans trois ans
exactement.
Nous travaillons, au ministère de
l'Education nationale, sur des
perspectives pluriannuelles en
lien et en collaboration avec les
collectivités.
Nous devons penser les questions
de ruralité de manière globale, et
c'est pour cela que j'échange et
que je travaille avec ma collègue
Dominique Faure de manière à ne
pas penser en silo les services de
l'Etat, mais dans leur globalité.
Le dernier point que je voudrais
souligner, c'est le fait que nous
sommes actuellement au mois de
mars.
Des ajustements ont lieu et auront
lieu jusqu'au mois de juin, voir
jusqu'à la fin du mois d'août.
- Alexandre Portier: Vous ne
répondez donc pas à la question.
C'est bien dommage.
Vous ne pouvez pas justifier les
fermetures de classes par une
baisse de la démocratie scolaire
quand nous avons les classes les
plus surchargées de toute l'OCDE.
Il faut se dire la vérité, les
classes que l'on ferme ne rouvrent
jamais.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Laure Miller.
- Laure Miller: Madame la
présidente, mes chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Transition écologique.
Monsieur le ministre, le GIEC a
publié hier son sixième rapport.
Le constat prend la forme d'une
alerte.
Nous devons aller plus loin et
surtout aller plus vite.
Ce rapport est un message
d'espoir, car nous avons le
savoir-faire, la technologie, les
outils et les ressources
financières pour surmonter les
problèmes climatiques que nous
avons identifiés.
Autre message important de ce
rapport, notre investissement dans
la transition écologique sera
forcément gagnant.
Les bénéfices d'une limitation du
réchauffement à 2 degrés seront
plus importants que le coût que
pourrait avoir le dépassement de
ce seuil.
Pour la première fois, un
président de la République a été
élu en 2022 sur un programme de
planification écologique et sur
l'idée de fixer enfin une
trajectoire claire, ambitieuse,
secteur par secteur, territoire
par territoire, afin d'embarquer
l'ensemble des forces vives de ce
pays.
Sur les questions énergétiques en
particulier, notre Assemblée est à
l'oeuvre.
La planification est en cours.
Nous devons accélérer le
renouvelable et le nucléaire.
Ce que dit aussi le GIEC, c'est
que ces transformations de fond
ont plus de chances de porter
leurs fruits lorsque règne la
confiance, lorsque les avantages
et les charges se répartissent
équitablement.
Ma question est double: à quel
niveau d'avancement sommes-nous
dans la mise en place de cette
planification écologique?
Comment garantir que celle-ci se
fasse de la façon la plus juste
possible?
Comment éviter une transition
écologique vécue comme punitive
par nos concitoyens?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée, je voudrais, au
lendemain de la publication de ce
rapport, rendre hommage à Valérie
Masson Delmotte qui, depuis huit
ans, préside un des groupes de
travail du GIEC de ce sixième
cycle.
Son investissement en France au
sein du Haut conseil pour le
climat, mais plus largement sur le
plan mondial, est crucial.
Après avoir dit ça, le rapport dit
qu'on ne peut pas nier le
réchauffement climatique, ni son
origine humaine à un moment où les
réseaux sociaux sont en train de
faire face à une résurgence des
fake news et d'un
climato-scepticisme qui se
généralise.
Le rapport insiste sur le fait
qu'il faut accélérer sur
l'atténuation.
Même les pays qui ont commencé à
baisser leurs émissions ne sont
pas dans le bon rythme.
Nous devons doubler le rythme de
baisse de nos émissions par
rapport au quinquennat précédent.
Comment faire?
Avec la planification écologique,
avec des feuilles de décarbonation
par secteur.
Avec une stratégie qui repose sur
des énergies décarbonées, le
renouvelable et le nucléaire, de
manière à éviter les erreurs
allemandes avec la réouverture des
mines de charbon que nous
connaissons.
Le rapport dit que quels que
soient les efforts que les pays
feront, à la minute où nous les
ferons, nous ne serons pas sur la
bonne trajectoire.
Le choix validé par la Première
ministre est d'adapter notre pays
à une augmentation des
températures qui pourrait
atteindre 4 degrés, ce n'est pas
du défaitisme, mais du réalisme,
ce qui nous permet d'accélérer sur
l'atténuation et de faire en sorte
de conduire les investissements
nécessaires.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Marcellin Nadeau.
- Marcellin Nadeau: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
délégué aux Outre-mer.
Madame la Première ministre a
refusé 19 députés des 10
outre-mer.
Le gouvernement a rejeté par le
biais de l'article 49.3 la plupart
des mesures votées à l'unanimité
lors de l'examen de la mission
outre-mer du projet de loi de
finances 2023.
Pas une loi votée par cette
assemblée n'a été consacrée,
depuis le premier quinquennat de
l'actuel président de la
République, aux 10 outre-mer, y
compris sur les retraites.
Vous gérez donc nos territoires
par ordonnance.
Nous, députés des 10 outre-mer,
ayant depuis le début de cette
législature essuyé un refus de la
part de ce gouvernement de prendre
en compte les spécificités des
problématiques de nos territoires.
Voici que par arrêté, vous,
monsieur le ministre délégué aux
Outre-mer, vous avez choisi de
vous séparer d'un collaborateur.
Il est établi par de nombreux
observateurs que le seul tort de
cet ancien conseiller est d'avoir
voulu dialoguer avec les petits
planteurs de bananes autour de
leurs difficultés.
C'est à la demande des grands
propriétaires terriens et des
lobbys de l'import-export que vous
auriez pris la décision de
remercier ce monsieur.
Alors, monsieur le ministre,
est-il vrai que vous avez agi sur
ordre des lobbys dont personne
n'ignore l'existence?
En dépit de l'unique décision de
non-lieu, la part de
responsabilité dans le scandale de
nos outre-mer?
Cela montrerait la collusion de
votre gouvernement avec les
puissances oligarchiques.
Monsieur le ministre, que
comptez-vous faire pour sortir à
la fois de la tyrannie de
l'indifférence, comme dirait Aimé
Césaire, vis-à-vis de nos
territoires et de cette relation
empreinte de colonialisme et de
collusion entre l'Etat et les
oligarchies?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, mon
cher collègue.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Véran.
- Olivier Véran: Monsieur le
député, vous l'aurez constaté, je
ne suis pas Jean-François Carenco.
J'excuse son absence.
Je crois qu'il est en déplacement
en territoire ultramarin.
Je vais essayer de circonscrire la
réponse à un élément factuel de
votre question qui portait sur les
petits planteurs de bananes.
Je crois comprendre que ça
pourrait être l'objet de la
discorde.
Je veux d'abord rappeler que la
filière des petits planteurs de
bananes est une filière qui
compte.
Dans les Antilles, 1 actif sur 20
travaille dans cette filière.
Elle compte actuellement 600
exploitations familiales.
Elle fait face aujourd'hui à des
enjeux qui nécessitent une
intervention.
Il y a notamment une maladie qui
peut toucher les bananes, mais
cela concerne également le
changement climatique, qui a un
impact sur cette filière, ou e
encore l'augmentation des coûts de
production.
Plusieurs mesures ont été prises
pour venir en aide aux
exploitants, parmi lesquelles la
reprise de 50% des exploitants sur
leurs achats engagés et un
étalement sur trois ans de la
dette restante.
Il y a également une aide de
l'Etat principalement destiné aux
petits planteurs.
Vous avez semblé incriminer le
départ d'un collaborateur sur la
base des relations qu'il aurait
avec les planteurs.
Pour remettre les faits au milieu
du village, les actions qui sont
conduites actuellement par l'Etat
sont faites pour venir en aide aux
petits planteurs de bananes.
Il y a d'autres engagements qui
vont se poursuivre dans leur
application et dans la
concertation, d'une part avec des
trajectoires adaptées aux besoins
locaux et une loi d'orientation et
d'avenir agricole.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Laurent
Panifous pour le groupe LIOT.
- Laurent Panifous: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de l'Industrie.
En Ariège, plusieurs territoires
sont parmi les plus sinistrés de
France, victimes de la crise
industrielle du textile.
C'est aussi un bassin qui fait
preuve de résilience et qui peut
compter sur l'appui et le
dynamisme de la région Occitanie
et de ses intercommunalités.
Cette résilience a permis
notamment à nos entreprises de
s'adapter et de réagir rapidement
pendant la crise sanitaire en se
réinventant pour mettre à profit
leur savoir-faire et leur
expertise dans le textile.
Elles ont ainsi permis de produire
rapidement les masques, blouses et
autres produits qui faisaient
cruellement défaut.
Cette pandémie a mis à jour une
cruelle réalité: la
désindustrialisation massive de
notre pays, notamment en ce qui
concerne les produits
stratégiques.
L'exemple des masques et des
blouses est frappant, mais il en
va de même pour les médicaments ou
les composants électroniques.
Ces entreprises qui ont assuré les
livraisons en urgence, ces
entreprises qui représentent
l'avenir des filières
traditionnelles sur le territoire
se sont vues écartées de la
commande publique une fois la
crise terminée, comme si rien ne
s'était passé.
Elles proposent une fabrication
durable, respectueuse des
exigences environnementales, lors
des appels d'offres émis, elles ne
peuvent pas concurrencer les
entreprises étrangères qui cassent
les prix avec des produits qui ne
sont pas réutilisables, qui sont
jetables, de mauvaise qualité et
qui sont fabriqués dans des
conditions discutables.
En Ariège, les exemples ne
manquent pas.
Il y a de nombreuses entreprises
qui nous offrent une réelle
capacité de développement
industriel, de création d'emplois
dans un département qui en manque
cruellement.
Pour ces entreprises, leurs
salariés, dans quelle mesure
l'Etat peut-il soutenir nos
industries dans cet objectif de
souveraineté industrielle?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Roland
Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Merci.
Monsieur le député, merci pour
votre question, qui nous permet de
rappeler que la politique
industrielle de ce gouvernement et
de cette majorité vise avant tout
à accélérer la réindustrialisation
de la France qui a été entamée
depuis un quinquennat et quelques
mois.
Le secteur du textile fait partie
des victimes des 50 dernières
années, il s'est progressivement
vu bouté hors de France pour aller
produire ailleurs des produits que
nous savions produire.
Vous l'avez dit, la crise
sanitaire a été l'occasion pour
ces entreprises de relocaliser et
de reproduire en France.
Les régions étaient au
rendez-vous.
Je me permets de vous rappeler que
l'Etat a été également au
rendez-vous par des aides directes
pour un certain nombre
d'entreprises de votre
département.
Nous devons aller plus loin.
Vous le savez, avec Bruno Le
Maire, nous travaillons à un
projet de loi qui vise à accélérer
la réindustrialisation en
profitant du fait que le
verdissement, la transition
écologique doive être une
opportunité pour les industries.
Nous devons refabriquer des
produits du textile quotidien.
au Nous devons rapatrier également
des produits comme des voitures,
notamment les véhicules
électriques, mais nous devons
aussi mieux utiliser tous les
leviers, notamment celui de la
commande publique pour accompagner
nos industries.
La bonne nouvelle, c'est que pour
la première fois depuis longtemps,
la Commission européenne semble
reconnaître que les critères
environnementaux et notre capacité
à assurer la sécurité des
approvisionnements, notamment pour
les objets que vous avez
mentionnés, ils sont prêts à les
intégrer dans le code des marchés
publics.
Nous sommes également prêts à le
faire.
Je vous engage à continuer à
accompagner le gouvernement plutôt
que de voter sa censure de manière
à ce que nous puissions continuer
à réindustrialiser ce pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno
Fuchs pour le groupe démocrate.
- Bruno Fuchs: Madame la
présidente, chers collègues, nous
avons célébré avec 87 autres pays
la Journée internationale de la
francophonie, c'était hier.
L'occasion pour les francophones
du monde entier de se rappeler
qu'ils constituent ensemble une
communauté vivante et d'avenir,
l'occasion aussi de se féliciter
de la décision de la France
d'organiser le prochain sommet de
la francophonie en France.
Pour le monde entier, c'est un
signal fort, celui de voir notre
pays s'engager clairement dans le
réenchantement de l'espace
francophone.
Il y a urgence car la francophonie
est plus que jamais en danger.
Elle est menacée dans ses
fondements mêmes, menacée d'un
côté par un capitalisme débridé,
de l'autre par la montée des
néo-impérialismes comme la Russie
ou les Chinois.
Renforcer la francophonie, c'est
défendre l'Etat de droit, les
libertés publiques, la vision
multilatérale du monde, valeurs
pour lesquelles nous nous battons
au quotidien.
Elle est menacée également dans
ses pratiques quotidiennes.
En 1998, il y avait 36% des textes
qui étaient écrits à la Commission
européenne en français.
Aujourd'hui, ce ne sont plus que
2%.
Dans la littérature scientifique
et médicale, seuls 0,3% le sont en
langue française.
Quel signal envoyons-nous à
certains étudiants?
Nous utilisons également beaucoup
d'anglicismes.
La francophonie est à la croisée
des chemins.
A cet égard, sachez que
l'Assemblée parlementaire de la
francophonie et ses 91 membres
autour d'un président canadien et
d'un vice-président gabonais,
jouera tout son rôle.
Vous l'avez compris, il faut agir
vite.
Quelle politique allez-vous mener
pour réinventer un modèle qui
susciterait adhésion et espoir
pour nos populations?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Chrysoula
Zacharopoulou.
- Chrysoula Zacharopoulou: Merci.
Monsieur le député, comme vous
l'avez dit, en cette semaine de la
francophonie, nous célébrons la
langue française.
Cette langue tellement dynamique
qu'elle est parlée sur les cinq
continents.
N'en déplaise aux déclinistes,
mais notre langue n'est pas en
recul.
Elle reste aujourd'hui la
cinquième langue la plus parlée et
la deuxième langue étrangère la
plus apprise au monde.
Partout, le Français est synonyme
d'échanges commerciaux, de
création culturelle et
d'opportunités d'emploi et de
formation.
Sous l'impulsion du président de
la République, nous agissons avec
madame la ministre Catherine
Colonna pour renforcer la place de
la langue française.
Nous le faisons en soutenant le
système éducatif de nos
partenaires dans l'espace
numérique
mais aussi dans les milieux des
affaires et des entreprises et
dans les institutions
internationales.
Des rendez-vous très importants
auront lieu dans les prochains
mois avec l'ouverture à l'été de
la cité internationale de la
langue française, à
Villers-Cotterêts, ce sera un lieu
magnifique de création,
d'apprentissage et d'innovation.
Comme vous l'avez très bien dit,
nous travaillons sur le 19e sommet
de la francophonie qui aura lieu
en France en 2024.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Rodrigo
Arenas pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Rodrigo Arenas: Madame la
présidente, monsieur le ministre,
10 mois, cela fait 10 mois que
votre gouvernement est à l'oeuvre
et qu'il maltraite les Françaises
et les Français.
Personne n'est épargné, pas même
nos professeurs qui ont pourtant
entre leurs mains l'avenir de la
France, c'est-à-dire nos enfants.
Hier, vous leur avez promis des
hausses de salaires tellement
minimes que nos enseignants
resteront toujours moins bien
payés que la moyenne de leurs
collègues européens.
D'ailleurs, cette aumône que vous
appelez le Pacte enseignant vient
d'être rejeté par l'ensemble des
représentants des professeurs.
Aujourd'hui, vous fermez leurs
classes, aggravant leurs
conditions de travail, et demain,
est-ce que vous les obligerez à
travailler davantage avant de
pouvoir profiter de leur retraite?
Quelle maltraitance!
Vous justifiez tout cela en nous
expliquant que le pays n'a pas les
moyens, qu'il faut faire des
économies.
C'est d'ailleurs la seule raison
que vous avez trouvée pour nous
imposer votre réforme des
retraites injuste et injustifiée.
Mais pour les écoles privées, les
moyens, vous les avez trouvés.
Dans ces écoles, puisque vous y
scolarisez vos enfants, ce sont
nos impôts qui financent le
salaire de leurs enseignants, ce
sont nos impôts qui leur
permettent d'avoir plus d'heures
d'enseignement et c'est avec nos
impôts qu'ils contournent la
mixité sociale et la mixité
scolaire.
Je vous le demande, monsieur le
ministre, puisque vous n'avez
qu'une vision comptable du monde,
quand allez-vous cesser de
privilégier l'école privée au
détriment de l'école publique?
Quand allez-vous enfin investir
dans notre école publique 100%
laïque, la seule à garantir un
accueil universel à tous les
enfants?
Quand allez-vous faire le choix de
l'intérêt général?
Pour 1 euro que vous donnez à
l'école privée, c'est 1 euro que
vous retirez à l'école publique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye, ministre de l'Education
nationale et de la Jeunesse.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Monsieur le député, vous parlez de
maltraitance, je veux bien que ces
temps-ci, le langage soit fleuri,
mais il dépasse les bornes.
Le budget du ministère de
l'Education nationale augmente de
6,5%, plus 6 milliards d'euros
cette année.
Quelle maltraitance!
Permettez-moi de vous dire que les
informations que vous fournissez
sont mal étayées.
Vous vous moquez du monde par
votre intervention.
+3,5 milliards d'euros, nous
allons augmenter et vous semblez
l'ignorer, les enseignants de deux
manières, d'une part par le socle.
C'est 1,9 milliard d'euros pour
tous les enseignants.
Cela concerne également les
néotitulaires et ceux qui sont en
fin de carrière.
Nous sommes en concertation
permanente avec les organisations
syndicales.
Nous aurons l'occasion de préciser
cette augmentation du socle.
Elle sera valable pour tout le
monde.
Et puis, il y a l'augmentation du
Pacte qui sera en effet lié à de
nouvelles missions dont nous avons
besoin pour améliorer les services
de l'école, en particulier pour
faire face à la question des 15
millions d'heures annuelles qui
sont perdues faute de
remplacements.
Nous aurons aussi la possibilité
de développer les sixièmes
tremplins grâce à des
enseignements de français et de
mathématiques qui seront assurés
par les professeurs des écoles.
Plutôt que de vous lancer dans des
propos démagogiques qui n'ont
aucun sens, regardez les chiffres,
monsieur le député.
Soyez sérieux et faites votre
travail, c'est-à-dire regardez les
données plutôt que de faire des
moulinets qui n'ont aucune
signification.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Rodrigo Arenas: Le manque de
sérieux, c'est vous qui ne l'avez
pas.
Vous direz ça à tous les parents
et tous les enfants qui seront
dans des classes surchargées dans
toutes les villes de France...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Nicolas
Dragon pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Nicolas Dragon: Merci.
Mes chers collègues, ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de l'Economie et des Finances.
Hier matin, je suis allé
rencontrer la direction de Rinaldi
Structal et les ouvriers salariés
du leader de la façade haute
technologie en aluminium basé dans
mon département de l'Aisne.
Après avoir souffert de la crise
Covid et de la crise énergétique,
l'usine est menacée de fermeture.
Cette entreprise est un fleuron de
notre industrie et nous devons
contrôler les façades du bâtiment
dans lequel vous travaillez.
Je peux aussi citer la pyramide du
Louvre, le musée du quai Branly,
l'opéra Bastille ou encore la
rénovation de la tour Pleyel
transformée demain en hôtel pour
les JO de Paris 2024.
Allez-vous leur dire que leur
savoir-faire peut tomber demain
dans l'oubli, que mon département
déjà fortement touché par le
chômage et la perte d'habitants
doit encore souffrir d'une unité
de production qui disparaît alors
que l'entreprise fonctionne,
exporte à l'étranger et a pour
projet d'embaucher?
Les salariés sont motivés.
Ils ont sacrifié leurs congés et
leur vie de famille pour bosser
plus.
Votre "quoi qu'il en coûte" n'est
peut-être plus d'actualité, mais
il faut sauver cette entreprise
dont le carnet de commandes
court jusqu'à l'année
prochaine.
La souveraineté industrielle que
vous défendez doit être plus que
des mots ou un simple concept.
Elle doit se concrétiser en actes
forts.
Qu'avez-vous l'intention de faire
pour toutes ces PME souvent
inconnues du grand public, mais au
savoir-faire incomparable?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Olivia
Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci.
Monsieur le député Dragon, je vais
déjà commencer par répondre très
simplement en lieu et place de
Bruno Le Maire.
Je suggère que nous échangions
très précisément sur la situation
de l'entreprise que vous
mentionnez, et bien entendu des 80
salariés que vous mentionnez.
Vous avez mentionné le "quoi qu'il
en coûte".
Nous l'avons dépassé pour des
raisons qui semblent évidentes,
mais quoi qu'il advienne, nous
sommes aux côtés des salariés, des
PME, des PMI, des entreprises qui
peuvent connaître des difficultés
en ce moment, et nous savons qu'il
y en a un certain nombre.
Hors de toute polémique, de façon
très froide, je suggère que nous
parlions de la situation
éventuellement avec le ministre de
l'Industrie pour voir si nous
pouvons prendre acte de la
situation de l'entreprise.
Sur le reste, je n'ai pas très
envie de polémiquer inutilement.
Votre question est très claire.
A nous de trouver des réponses.
Il faut que l'on prenne la mesure
de la situation de cette
entreprise.
Pour ce qui est d'être aux côtés
des salariés et des entreprises,
pour lutter contre l'inflation,
que ce soit celle des ménages ou
des matières premières, nous
sommes à leurs côtés.
Je rappelle des chiffres
importants.
Juste sur l'année 2023, rien que
le bouclier tarifaire pour les
salariés, c'est 46 milliards
d'euros de présence de l'Etat.
C'est l'équivalent d'une guerre
pour battre l'inflation.
Nous sommes aux côtés des
entreprises.
12 milliards d'euros sont en train
d'arriver sur les factures
d'énergie, pour accompagner
d'autres entreprises.
Il y a d'autres sujets et d'autres
problèmes.
Prenons quelques minutes pour en
parler ensemble.
On va regarder ça très
précisément.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Nicolas Dragon: Merci, madame la
ministre, pour cette bonne foi.
Je vous invite à venir dans cette
entreprise avec moi parce que,
franchement, les larmes qui
coulent sur les joues des
salariés, ce n'est plus
supportable pour personne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Louis Thiériot pour le groupe
Les Républicains.
- Jean-Louis Thiériot: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le garde des Sceaux.
La France a besoin de prisons, et
faute de place, vous avez donné
l'instruction aux procureurs
généraux "de donner la priorité à
chaque fois que cela est possible
aux peines alternatives à
l'emprisonnement".
Cette absence de construction de
places de prison reste largement à
l'origine de l'inflation de la
délinquance que nous connaissons.
15.000 places promises, 2000
construites.
Il faut construire des prisons,
mais il faut en construire
opportunément, au bon endroit, en
tenant compte de la cohérence de
l'action publique.
Notre pays, et nous nous en
félicitons, a fait le choix
d'aller vers une politique de
lutte contre l'artificialisation
des terres.
Or, vous avez fait le choix de
construire une prison au milieu de
terres agricoles, sur une commune
de ma circonscription de
Seine-et-Marne.
La décision n'a fait l'objet
d'aucune concertation sérieuse
avec les habitants qui l'ont vécu
comme un véritable bras d'honneur
aux communes rurales.
Lors de la visite de vos services
dans la commune, la semaine
dernière, l'Agence publique pour
l'immobilier et la justice a
présenté les décisions comme
arrêtées et a toujours refusé de
faire une étude comparative.
D'autres solutions étaient
possibles.
Je pense en particulier à la
friche industrielle du clos
Saint-Louis dans la ville de
Dammarie-les-Lys.
Ma question est très simple, y
a-t-il une cohérence entre la
politique de la justice et la
politique de l'environnement?
Renoncez à ce site.
Il n'est pas trop tard pour
conjuguer justice et écologie et
pour en faire un exemple de
l'action de l'Etat.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu, ministre de la
Transition écologique et de la
Cohésion des territoires.
- Christophe Béchu: Monsieur le
député, je reconnais que c'est
assez singulier que ce soit moi
qui réponde à une question
qui est adressée au garde des
Sceaux.
Je l'excuse car vous avez vu qu'il
ne pouvait pas être parmi nous.
La question de la compatibilité
éventuelle, de la lutte contre
l'artificialisation et la
construction de prisons, il me
revient d'y répondre.
Cela s'inscrit dans un projet de
construction de 15.000 places de
prison présenté le 20 avril 2021,
qui fait face au constat de la
surpopulation carcérale.
Ce n'est pas le nombre de prisons
qui doit diriger les décisions des
juges.
Les décisions pénales doivent être
appropriées.
Je ne pense pas que vous contestez
le nombre de places de prison,
puisque c'est moins que ce que
François Fillon et Valérie
Pécresse avaient proposé.
Dès le mois d'avril 2021, ce site
a été identifié.
Vous avez posé une question écrite
au mois d'octobre et dans la
continuité, la réponse qui vous a
été faite, c'est que ce site situé
sur un terrain agricole a d'abord
été choisi par la communauté de
communes et ensuite sur une zone
qui était de toute façon prévue
pour une trajectoire
d'artificialisation et qui, dans
les documents d'urbanisme locaux,
n'avait plus vocation à avoir
cette nature agricole.
En parallèle, la semaine dernière,
le gouvernement, conformément aux
engagements qu'il avait pris, a
déposé un amendement dans le cadre
de l'examen de la proposition de
loi sénatoriale pour faire en
sorte d'amender le dispositif de
zéro artificialisation nette, pour
préciser que les grands projets
d'envergure nationale ne devaient
pas faire l'objet d'une
comptabilité par commune, mais
faire l'objet d'un décompte à
part, que ce soit pour les sujets
qui relèvent de la souveraineté,
de la décarbonation ou du
régalien.
Ces deux trajectoires ne sont pas
incompatibles compte tenu de cet
amendement et du texte qui vous
sera soumis bientôt.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Béatrice Piron pour le
groupe Renaissance.
- Béatrice Piron: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre des Solidarités et des
Personnes handicapées de France.
Monsieur le ministre, vendredi 17
mars 2023 a eu lieu la première
Journée nationale des aides à
domicile.
Cette journée a été l'occasion de
rappeler le rôle essentiel de ces
professionnels, un maillon crucial
de la vie quotidienne des
personnes en perte d'autonomie,
qu'elles soient en situation de
handicap, malades ou âgées.
Les aides à domicile accompagnent
leur quotidien et leur permettent
de rester dans leur propre foyer
afin de vivre à domicile, choix
partagé par plus de 85% des
Français.
Je profite également de cette
occasion pour remercier les
conseils départementaux et les
organisations qui ont célébré
cette première journée nationale
avec des aides à domicile
nombreuse ce jour-là.
Avant d'être élue, j'ai travaillé
dans le secteur de l'aide à
domicile auprès de personnes âgées
et je reste en contact régulier
avec des professionnels de mon
département.
Vendredi, ils me confiaient encore
que leur secteur d'activité était
toujours plus en tension et en
difficulté, au point de craindre
la fermeture de quelques
organisations.
Il y a donc une nécessité
constante de revaloriser ce métier
et de les soutenir, eux qui se
sont tant mobilisés pendant la
pandémie de Covid, eux qui
prennent soin de nos aînés.
Une proposition de loi pour le
bien-vieillir en France va être
débattue au sein de notre
hémicycle.
Parmi ses objectifs: plusieurs
mesures concernent l'amélioration
et l'accompagnement de ces aides à
domicile.
Pouvez-vous nous préciser les
prochaines mesures que vous
envisagez de mettre en place afin
de valoriser cette profession
essentielle et plus largement
faciliter le quotidien de nos
aînés et de ces professionnels?
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Christophe Combe.
- Jean-Christophe Combe: Madame la
députée, je vous remercie pour
votre question qui me donne
l'opportunité de revenir sur la
première journée des aides à
domicile et cette belle réussite.
J'ai eu le plaisir de l'organiser
avec l'ensemble du secteur, avec
les professionnels, pour les
remercier pour leur engagement,
pour les remercier et pour mettre
en valeur la place essentielle qui
est la leur dans notre solidarité
nationale.
Nous le savons tous, pour
concrétiser le virage domiciliaire
et pour faire du souhait
majoritaire des Français de rester
à domicile une réalité, nous
devons recruter des aides à
domicile et nous leur devons une
totale reconnaissance.
Nous le devons à Suzane, à Nadia,
à toutes celles et ceux qui me
disent aimer exercer leur métier,
un métier dont toutes les
personnes âgées ou en situation de
handicaps qui sont accompagnées
connaissent l'importance.
Depuis la crise sanitaire, nous
avons agi.
On a multiplié les actions de
soutien avec des revalorisations
salariales sans précédent ou
encore en renforçant les
structures via la mise en place
d'un tarif plancher et d'une
dotation qualité.
La situation n'est bien sûr pas
parfaite, mais nous avons continué
à agir,
que ce soit via le
CNR-bien-vieillir ou la
proposition de loi que vous avez
mentionnée ou via le Plan métier
que nous travaillons avec
l'ensemble du gouvernement à la
demande de la Première ministre.
On prendra les mesures nécessaires
pour continuer à revaloriser ces
métiers, je parle de la
revalorisation salariale, mais
aussi de l'organisation du travail
et du parcours.
On doit organiser l'équilibre
entre leur vie professionnelle et
leur vie personnelle.
Il y a des propositions en ce sens
dans la proposition de loi dont
vous parliez.
Cette politique, je la porte sur
l'ensemble
de mon champ d'action et avec
l'ensemble des professionnels.
J'en profite pour rappeler
qu'aujourd'hui, c'est la Journée
internationale du travail social.
Cela me permet de rendre hommage à
ces travailleurs qui sont si
utiles à notre nation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La séance est terminée.
La séance est suspendue pour une
durée de 15 minutes.